très bien tous étaient 102 trésor
aujourd'hui en janvier ont alors tenté
l'ordre c'est plus compliqué le canal du
midi à côté rocher des fonds d'art du
coran mais regardez moi c'est plus je
pense que ça en valait le coup on a déjà
fait un outil on a trouvé une sorte
d'arbre de pignons de l'auteur donc on
va voir
c'est parti on n'espère pas tomber sur
quelque chose de trop gros également
premier personnes
lancée quelques semaines
le bas
trop fort
[Musique]
non
ok
avant de changer
est-ce que tu
twitter
dale bobines de cuivre
on voit l'intérieur qui a activé sa
cellule bien on garde
il a la flemme de se mouiller mais ils
le font parce qu'il a coincé sans les
mains et la règle de base c'est celui
qui coince on dément plonge
bon par contre qu'il a pris le maillot
je dis que je voulais lui en prin-times
on n'aura pas besoin moi du coup il y
avait peut-être besoin
pas grave il en slip mois les au moins à
28 à face ils allaient entretien
il dit quoi le fond
c'est le bordel
alors
tant il à pied ça va
super dur on peut à parfaire fait
trempette
on décroche un aimant la fête de la
pêche aliments en fait on jette des
aimants pour ramasser tout ce qui est
magnétique et sauf que là il s'est
coincé sur un truc assez ça c'est le
risque
bon ça va c'est pas trop ça le dépasser
dans le canal du midi alors ouais merci
ouais jusqu'au bout dit tu vois rien là
à travers
alors
ah ouais une énorme poutre
ayasse sauvetage réussie
il ya plein de trucs groupe regarde une
chaise
pas
bon
talât dans la terre la base je vais
lancer sur un truc c'est demain
[Applaudissements]
en quantité oui mais il ya autre chose
oui tout ça
et un truc en plus ça le pire
sa pensée de la fente cimetière lourd
que des trucs lourds ou des chaises
tabourets ont couvertes 25e sur balles à
pas une giclée c'est quoi ce truc non
ange pour que ce joli
parce que c'est
passer de la fonte
regardez comme c'est dégueulasse à à
quelques mètres du pont regardez ça
sorte directement des habitations
dégueulasse avec une bonne odeur des
gueux et des papier déchiqueté ça veut
dire que totalement faux c'est
dégueulasse c'était beau mais l'eau doit
être horrible on va chercher un meilleur
spot pass qui avait pas grand chose ici
peut-être en face à voir
rien du tout ouais on va aller au bord 5
centimes
ouais drôle de blague
un truc
ils voteront par non je vais retourner
dans l'eau un trousseau de clés ouais
plein de clé à regarde que des petites
encore de partir je remettrai ça dans
l'eau pour max a pu mesurer tout dans
l'eau
avantage inversée au lieu de jeter
langues
[Musique]
bon pas bougé la balle